(music)
I''m Mike McGehee and I'm a Professor in
Materials Science Engineering at Stanford University.
I'm also a senior fellow in
the Precourt Institute for Energy.
And I am the director of the Energy
certificate program.
I have a degree in physics from Princeton University
and a PhD in materials science from University of California, Santa Barbara.
Ah, when I was a graduate student, ah, I saw the opportunity to apply to be a professor at Stanford.
I was initially disappointed because it was my dream job and I thought I was too young but I went for it
I applied and I got it. And here I am. I find solar cell
research to be fascinating because there
are so many different possible solutions
to the problem. And as someone who's been
working in the field for over 15 years I
know my mind has been changed several
times on what the most promising
approach is. Ah, my lab works on several
different kinds of solar cells. We take a
holistic view towards it and study
everything from how they're made, to how
they work, to ah, what they would cost. And we
tried interact with industry to make sure
we're developing effective solutions.
(music to fade out)